neovim a highly extensible
keyboard-based editor designed to
optimize the productivity of modern
programmers in 1976 Bill Joy created VI
in 1991 it was improved by Bram mullinar
as Vim then in 2014 neovim came along
it's a fork of them making it a drop in
replacement that's 99 identical for
basic usage all of your favorite help I
can't exit Vim memes are still perfectly
valid but its code base was restructured
with well-documented apis that Embrace
new features from the community which
has resulted in a thriving plug-in
ecosystem most importantly scripting can
be accomplished in not only vimscript
but also Lua an easy to learn
multi-paradigm language that's also used
on platforms like Roblox Lua was used to
write its built-in language server
protocol for code Auto completion it has
a scriptable terminal emulator in
addition to tons of awesome plugins like
telescope a fuzzy finder that can search
across your file system to get started
install neovim then open it with the
nvim command it just like regular Vim
hit I to go into insert mode and start
typing then hit escape to go back to
normal mode use a colon to enter command
mode like when you need to ask the
computer for help but the fun thing
about neovim is customization which can
be handled with the traditional init.vin
file or alternatively in a knit.lua file
inside this file we can use Lua code to
configure basic settings like whether or
not to use tabs or spaces as the config
grows more complex we can break it into
modules in the Lua folder which will
automatically be loaded by neovim from
there we can use a package manager like
Packer to install a color theme like one
dark and some icons to go along with it
you'll need an LSP server for code
completion you might also want nvim tree
to easily explore the file system tree
sitter for syntax highlighting and
Telescope to more efficiently search
across your project from here we can
further customize each plugin as needed
with its own dedicated Lua file now all
this configuration might feel a bit
overwhelming if you just want an IDE
with minimal effort simply install a
starter config like NV chat you'll have
syntax highlighting code completion
along with all kinds of other essential
tools and now you're ready to start
writing code like a 10x engineer now
that we're finished I could tell you how
to exit then but then I'd have to kill
you this has been neovim in 100 seconds
if you want to learn more subscribe to
TJ DeVries your leading expert on
everything neovim thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one